tell me you're a monika without telling
me you're a monika
i'll go first
[Music]
courtney cox is proving she really is
just like her friend's character
monica oh no was i cleaning in my sleep
again
and i do ask that when you're not using
the markers you put the caps back on
them
because they will dry out i got soap and
sponges and rags and
carnauba wax and polishing compound
like we said just like monica our
favorite compulsive cleaner
perfectionist and organizer
extraordinaire
i mean look at those drawers and that
pantry
i know i know this video is just further
proof that courtney is proving herself
to be quite
the social media star last year she
showed off her musical chops with
daughter
wrote coco from the moment i
read them i knew you were mine you said
you were
mine i thought you were mine
what does coco think of you being like
in the social media world
because you show on facebook now you got
an instagram like
well i mean yesterday coco was sick and
i sat down with her i said cook i'm
trying to do this story i think this
would be really funny
can you help me put music to this i
downloaded this app and i'm just trying
to edit this and
she's like mom it's just it's not fun
and then and then i just walked away and
she didn't know how to do the music so
it turns out
that you know she's got some stuff to
learn
being the talented pianist she is she
also recently covered
the friends theme song
and there's this cover of justin
bieber's holy
[Music]
the actress is also quite the talent in
the kitchen
showing followers how to make a
delicious chicken parmesan
[Music]
but back to the monika of it all the
debate tag
shouldn't be at the top left corner it
should be at the bottom
right corner her new video comes just as
the iconic
cast wrapped filming their friends
reunion special for hbo max
oh i i see you moved the green ottoman
how did that happen i can't wait for it
to happen i mean the six of us haven't
been
in a room together in front of people in
25 years and only once
a few years ago just privately for
dinner so and we had a great time
so i can only imagine it's going to be
fun i mean it'll be really fun
i think the cast is incredibly grateful
and want to give back you know by doing
this special
you